hans it's the end of your first super
tournament what did you think of your
play
in the game or overall overall
well
i think um
i have mixed feelings about my play
obviously because the the beginning
was starting i think my first four games
uh were i was so happy with
and i think in the first four games i i
could have likely i could even scored
four to four based on the chances and i
was winning in every single one of those
games
and then after that um
i just uh
the pressure of playing my first super
tournament combined with everything it
was uh it was a lot to handle and uh
i wasn't able to manage my nerves and in
many critical moments i just completely
choked
so obviously these
the second half was was very difficult
to place a strong opposition under such
pressure on and off the board
but i think considering the
circumstances the fact that i have
survived is a miracle
so i'm very happy with uh
at least
maybe not this game but
it's over and okay 50 if you include the
magnus win
with considering the circumstances i
think is a very good result and uh i
think that if i could play with the
claire mind and no drama i'm sure i
would have done much better before the
tournament did you imagine yourself
scoring 50 in the first try against
these 2700 plus imagine scoring higher
than that so
what did you feel about some of the
other games pressure got to you do you
feel that was the reason that you
weren't able to get some good positions
of course it's uh
immediately after round four uh i had my
routine was ruined i i was barely
sleeping
um i was waking up much later than usual
my preparation suffered
my i was much less calm i was extremely
nervous and anxious at the board because
when you're playing chess you need to
only be thinking about chess and you
simply can't afford to think about
anything else especially playing at such
a high level
so
i think i'm at least happy that i showed
my my ability to play under normal
circumstances
as we saw in these first four games
which were i think amazing to be honest
and
after that i guess i went into survival
mode and okay i lost these two games
against wesley and fabiano with white
and
that i should absolutely have never lost
these games um i
i think at fabio maybe there were like
four junctions
where i could have
i had like four chances
to just
you know shut things down
even more and i failed at every single
attempt just because
my mind wasn't in the right place
and uh against wesley this is just
completely uncalled for and okay when
your opponent plays the petrov you
should not be losing
you survived the tournament it's over
for you in the sink field cup you were
the center of a very tumultuous event
what are you going to do next
well um
i guess now that the tournament is over
it's time to
reflect on the chess first of all um and
to reflect how many things that had
happened and uh my next classical event
is the u.s championship so of course i'm
looking forward to that
and uh
i'm just i just hope to have a day where
i can uh
not look at social media and uh
just just enjoy life and be relaxed and
have a clear mind so i'm hoping that i
can i'm looking forward to some peace
and uh
i guess we're gonna some things we'll
see how things uh move forward you have
several weeks until the us championship
gets started you're gonna be playing
some of these top players there as well
what are you gonna be doing in those
weeks to prepare yourself mentally
well i think that uh having time to
recover first of all
will be really important
second of all
i think
just having a
stable routine is really important you
know in this tournament um in the first
few rounds i was
going to sleep at like 9 30 p.m
and i was waking up quite early i would
go swim laps for about a half an hour
then i would
eat at around the exact same time i
would prepare i would it was also
structured and also disciplined
and that kind of collapsed
at some point event and that had a very
detrimental effect and what you do off
the board
and how you prepare for the games
mentally physically is extremely
important especially at this level of
play so i wasn't able to maintain that
routine but i think that uh with more
physical exercise with more training and
again the experience from this event i
think will
be really really important because it's
my first super tournament classical and
uh
i think that there are a lot of sort of
tweaks that come into super tournament
chess speaking specifically about the
chess considering this is your first
super tournament what did you notice you
need to change
well um i definitely need to be more
risk-averse
if you have a spectrum and you compare
me and wesley
i would say that that is certainly a
parabolic
he's extremely risk-averse and
i've noticed that
each player is always extremely strong
but i've noticed differences in how they
make certain decisions at certain
moments
so obviously against wesley when i
played this move h4 lying at h5 i think
that any strong player would simply okay
take on f6 take on d5 i'm never going to
lose the game ever and that is a very
let's say
professional approach and these types of
conscious decisions will prevent
all unnecessary losses
and if you look at the losses in this
tournament it's not like i was
completely dominated not played they
were completely self-inflicted
um but the loss against white was he was
self-inflicted
the loss against white was
against fabi was completely
self-inflicted with his insane move g4
so
the law says that i'm not losing um
i'm losing because i'm
losing objectivity losing my calm and um
not
avoiding risk and that's simply the name
of the game like you look at a guy like
dominguez this is so so risk-averse and
it's really difficult to beat them
they're not gonna win a lot of games but
uh the important thing from my from my
opinion is just to take your chances and
the chances will come if you just like
if you can play nine games and never be
lost that's statistically you're going
to win some games do you feel this is
arrested you from playing so many opens
and so many people that are lower rated
than you no of course yeah the the the
playstyle needs to adapt and
um
that has been a really weird process
because when you gain so much reading so
quickly and you're
adapting from different
tournament structures the tournament
structure really requires a different
type of chess
for example these guys
shape their entire repertoire around
simply forcing uh a draw the most
concrete manner some players do it some
places don't but if you look at like jan
for example his repertoire was black
is uh it's it's he's wins a lot of games
black but
i it's not that hard to force a draw
against him with white and a lot of
players are like this so
perhaps i need to adjust
because if you play super super slow
openings right you make yourself much
less of a target
but i guess i guess i'll find my style
and i'll find what i like to play
and
but i think that uh
if i was i think that uh i need a little
bit of wesley
i need to is that that complete risk
aversion
and uh
really really making sure no blunders
happen is something that i think would
benefit me
a lot to balance out my ambition and
fighting spirit
the next super tunnel you're going to
play is the us championship we can
definitely call it a super tournament
what place are you expecting to get in
it
i'm expecting to play my best chess and
to
to improve upon this and uh if this is
any representation of my potential
i think that the us championship is
going to be even more impressive
considering this experience and
considering that i think i'm going to be
in a much better mental place during
that event right
tell us a little bit about the winner of
the grand chess tour you've got to play
here in this tournament alireza farrugia
that is
uh what do you think of his chess
he's pretty good yeah
so i we actually uh um
uh i've known him not known him but we
played actually in the under 12 in world
youth
in in greece so uh
i was always familiar with him and he
was sort of uh we're actually born one
day apart oh that's funny so he's always
been the
leading my age my year and then
obviously now the entire junior
generation so
i think he's representation of first of
all
how this fresh ambitious tracks can be
so uh dominating
and uh also just to show that uh
you know he's uh
an ex amazing work ethic and uh
extremely talented
so uh but as you see from him as well
sometimes in the candidates he was
taking you know ridiculous amount of
risk for no reason and so i think
i guess the younger players need to be
more professional
in some respects because
i think that some of these top 10 guys
would would never in their
mind play some of the moves that at
least i played because they're just
they would never think of even taking
any risk because it's just the smartest
way to play
yes i'm being told has a question to
jump in with
actually i have to first of all the
tumult that occurred off the board that
was terrible but at least it provided us
with two moments of gaiety i want to say
one you were coming into the playing
hall
with some chewing gum man and
you got wanted on that chewing gum like
it was you know the high
secrets and then the other one was
yesterday we had a quad of ladies who
showed up to express their great support
your your reflections first of all with
the ladies
uh well i actually found it after the
game i did not notice that
um
yeah that was certainly an interesting
uh surprise
and i saw someone made a reddit post
about that you know someone really is
desperate for reddit karma yes it's very
important numbers like uh alejandro i've
seen him he's farming radicarma like
crazy you know as a commenter and he
finally saw the chance to post
because you've just been lurking in the
reddit comments for a while now um
[Music]
that was i think that that is the first
time in chess that has ever happened
and um as i said in my interview with
anastasia i i think that this tournament
will go down in history
and um
um i think it'll be i think when people
look back on my career and i'm gonna
have a very very long career it's
apparently on the screen i was
definitely farming they'd read it they
read it
looks like you were enjoying yourself
there i think uh i had to run because we
have a seven minute break between
here and the studio that is the only
time i've seen you run alejandro
even
when we play tennis you don't run excuse
me who won who won that match because
because you play
you play you play tennis like wesley
plays chess
you just like but the thing is that you
don't you can't run so excuse me you're
very smart with the placement i'll tell
you you're the placement you're hitting
to my backhand every single time and you
got lucky it was our first set and
hadn't played in like a year
technique too strong the tennis speaks
for itself
so many things i can say right now
incredible yeah but okay the main point
is obviously this is the highlight of
your commentary
you know you're waiting just for this
moment right yes and finally in chess
you know it's an interesting concept
because
if you look at a lot of major sports
this is certainly a common thing right
but chess
to have like groupies
is a bit or fangirls
if that if that term is
denominatory um
is certainly unique and um
personally uh
i'm uh i think it's it's interesting for
sure
i don't know what to say here um thank
you for being my fans and uh
i will definitely not cut my hair now
because um
i really love my hair
and
the previous times i've cut it were all
by influence of a girl
so i'm not going to to let that mistake
repeat itself hanzo fabulous her
everybody knows curly hair is the best
yes yes it does
i have to echo what you said this will
go down as a tournament in history
above anything else i have done
commentary for the sing field cup since
it started in 2013 and never have i seen
the amount of attention that this one
has gotten and is there anything that
you would
finally like to add
well first of all um the fact that i'm
even playing this tournament was pure
chance
um
there was a last minute dropout and then
i was selected which was not guaranteed
and then i made a trip from turkey very
far and very tiring so
the fact that
the last three weeks seem like it's it's
parallel universe it's just doesn't make
any sense to me
because this wild card to miami for no
reason
and even there you know chess speaks for
itself and that went crazy and the last
uh it just felt like uh
quite crazy
but i'm very thankful first of all to
rex and jeannie sinfield
for everything you've done in chess like
this uh invitation
will definitely have a significant
impact on my career and we'll see if
that is positive
or negative and that's to be determined
but um
i'm just
very happy to play this tournament and i
hope i wish that i could have done
better
but um i think that i showed that i can
play with the best of the best and
regardless of the result i think that
that's something that no one can can
deny
has we will see you very soon here at
the us championships can't wait for
those games to start thanks for joining
us thank you thank you hans indeed our
congratulations for
your success
in